These
next excerpts are taken from the original tape. W
one seventy seven Side
B.
I was born he said Yeah I was born in the one where
three one the other we went through
the
mother. I got when I got
my
life put on I'm nobody on the night it's
radio yeah no
way no like even the end say of me.
Now going on
eight and I've been living here ever
since under sail. I don't know exactly what
why someone lives where your I don't where do you think you all
are you know that I'm leaving home and then
I want to move all the time I won't go anywhere.
When I was I
started and I stayed on the war didn't get
killed
ninety make your own woman quit right I
probably
you know I got
there I got a lot of grandchildren.
I get I got twenty nine
grandchildren and I got sick great
grandchildren in them got round a
great
great.
Did you know everything. He died I say you know your last words
just
then he said there is a new ad the making is no
are you going to stay in that.
I see the boats used to overlay my home or nobody.
Yeah I guess.
I
was you know I
quit I I did let go but yes it did take
you a an eight I didn't
eat any sick a long
time and they all know I
was the embodiment spilled
your good I'm saying your intellect
is
doing their part. There are a couple of books you know in your writing
we call
them in a that it's easy
that no one any other look I'm seeing you. I
guess ready go got the book right
having it so
hard is many pages. They gave
him earlier.
I'm not knowing.
They trapped in a boat led
drive and enjoyed
both girls
look
pretty then as the boat you come up to take the same
route share them a round merge
vague and say much more oversight when you
strike it's. There are words.
And just one of them all the lies they cry
and boy does it all.
Yeah
men who really
years. One
for them are
there any on my door
here. I know you're not
old enough to play school
can. We design become real where you want
to
get in there do it here or nice you are not
your history. He's a
real one here. Yes I will trip date.
This place gone tell the voice.
I'm not I'm not your birthday always do have a combined
with I will wait for I got home.
Well you see no way to we have no power both like the added in
another spot on his union. It's actually much money come home eating in the
round on won't get you a whole load you
when we get a corner work.
Now then the more Colombo's open we get or
yeah.
Yeah I know it turns
out.